constantinople used to be the center of
the greek speaking world it sat as the
capital of the roman empire and later
the ottoman empire which as you know
came to a spectacular end after it
joined the central powers in world war
one after its defeat the anton plan to
carve it up like this notably removing
constantinople and not giving it to the
greeks who very much wanted it which
raises the question why why wasn't
greece giving constantinople after world
war one so first some background when
the ottomans joined the first world war
russian leadership got very excited
because to them when they won they would
finally be getting their hands on
constantinople something which they had
coveted forever and would help cement
their position as the third rome and it
would also open up access to the
mediterranean for them the other great
powers in the antarete accepted this
concession because they really needed
russia however russia would never
control the city because in 1917 it was
time for a communist revolution so who
would get it afterwards well the anton
largely ignored the issue until the
ottomans were well and truly broken at
this point they negotiated the treaty of
saarv which divided the empire up like
this and constantinople was to become an
international zone just like the sarland
greece wasn't given a look in for
several reasons the first was the
international zone meant british in
albert name who as of the occupation had
a veto on all laws passed by the ottoman
government and also by gaining
constantinople britain would have
control over every entrance to the
mediterranean which sounded very useful
to them and thus it was not something
that they were willing to give up the
second reason was that greece wasn't
seen as important enough to own the city
constantinople was one of the great
cities of the world and greece was a
reluctant ally which wasn't exactly on
the best terms with the ontant the
greeks had pushed to gain this territory
collectively known as the magali plan
the anton would content to give them
some of this but constantinople was a
step too far whose inclusion would have
made greece into a middling european
power overnight furthermore the victors
didn't quite buy greece's claim to the
city under the guise of them being the
successes of byzantium british leaders
saw greece not as the continuation of an
ancient legacy but as a modern nation
state like romania and one whose german
king had no right to claim the
inheritance of rome and the third reason
is the really important one the turkish
had other plans whilst the ottoman
government begrudgingly accepted
partition the turkish people did not
resistance movements sprang up quickly
and soon came together under the
leadership of mustafa kamal he defeated
the greeks in the west who had landed to
take control of their new territories
well as the french in the south kamal
marched on constantinople where he was
presented with an ultimatum withdraw or
face total war which the british
government was happy to do alongside
their steadfast allies who had just
abandoned them since this wasn't seen as
important enough and also everyone had
had enough of war at this point as such
plan b resign and let your successor
deal with it this led to the allies
signing the treaty of luzon which
finalized the new nation of turkey's
borders and as you'll note greece wasn't
able to get constantinople because now
it was firmly turkeys i hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
with a special thanks to my patrons
james bisonette kelly moneymaker corso
wolff jerry lamden jordan longley adam
stalter y and hockey captain cydog rod d
martin marvin cassell spencer lightfoot
gustav swan common yoon boogerly wiggly
matthew shipley marcus asner the mc
whopper aaron the white max and flaurio
maggie paxkowski corey turner alex
schwinn anthony beckett spinning three
plates copper tone words about books
podcast winston cayward charles the
first ben evinson and scottish trekkie